now as before with your roots and
coefficients
and i'm trying to avoid drowning in a
sea of alphas and betas and gammas
these questions are really much the same
but they sort of
twist and turn in slightly different
shapes okay so i'm going to walk you
through one of them
uh one of the tricky ones actually and
hopefully it'll equip you enough to have
a go at the others and once you see that
inside you'll be like oh this is fine
it's just all um different variations on
the same theme okay here's a cubic
polynomial
the information they tell you apart from
these other coefficients
is it has a double integral root now
that's a bit sneaky
because some of you may be aware the
word integral has a very specific
meaning in mats
um it's it's meant to be about the
opposite of differentiation and
derivatives and that kind of thing
but in this case it's just about roots
and coefficients what do you think they
mean
did you have to take a guess it's an
integer it's just a whole number
right so what they mean
is that a polynomial right which has
degree three
we would expect to have three roots yes
some of them might be imaginary and that
kind of thing but in this case what
we're going to have is
two of them being equal to each other
okay
and not just being equal but integers so
i would say
therefore uh let the roots be
alpha alpha and beta
right where
alpha belongs to this set of numbers set
of whole numbers
all right okay now the question is just
to find k
now with all these questions in some
ways it's exactly the same as the
previous
type of question where you're trying to
find a evaluate alpha plus beta plus
gamma times blah blah blah blah
the way you always start is say take
your sum of roots
sum of roots two at a time and your
product of roots just get those numbers
out
okay now in this case because there's a
k right they're not gonna be numbers
they're gonna be equations that we're
gonna have to solve
right so let's start sum of roots
which would ordinarily be alpha plus
beta plus gamma but in this case
that's what i've said they are what's it
equal to
minus b on a right so minus b on a
there's that number okay so two alpha
plus beta let's sorry equals five let's
call that equation one
all right next equation is taking the
roots two at a time
right so the first product is going to
be alpha
squared right the next one will be these
two
and then the last one will be these two
which is actually the same
right so that's the sum of the route
to the time now that's equal to this is
minus b on a so this is c on a
so it's just going to be seven is that
okay
all right so i'll call that well let's
just simplify that
um call that equation two all right
last one product of all there is
together alpha by alpha by beta
so that's alpha squared beta
we said minus beyond a c on a so this is
minus
d on a so that's going to be
minus okay right
and that's equation three all right now
remember we're after
k in this case that's what we're
actually trying to solve the fact that
we've got three equations here
is a good sign because we've got three
unknowns alpha beta and k
all right basic rule of simultaneous
equations for every
variable or every unknown you're trying
to find you need one equation for it
okay
if you've got one equation and two
unknowns you're never gonna
salt what they are all right so if
that's what we've got what do you think
we should do as a first step to put them
together
what do you recommend yeah
good so you can see that equations one
and two are going to be good to go after
right because if we went straight for
three which is actually the one we're
going to be interested in we don't know
enough about it
for us to actually solve anything okay
whereas if i get another color
uh one and two right you just consider
those
you remember how i said this whole
question i've got three unknowns and
three equations right so i can solve it
well part of my first step would be two
unknowns alpha and beta and two
equations so i'm trying to reduce the
complexity of the problem
okay so what did justin say i think you
said to get this in terms of
beta all right so bring that over here
and i guess you've got beta equals
five minus two alpha okay
now i could probably call this equation
four
but that's a bad idea idea anyone know
why
i have to call it something but why not
four because it is
i am actually going to call it 1a that's
what i would here's why
here's why one a is a better name than
four
okay four is just you know it's the
fourth equation but it doesn't tell me
where the equation came from
okay but one a actually tells me look
this is my this is where i
started up this is my source of
information and the thing that it stops
you from doing
is putting this equation back into
itself right if you ever do that
all you end up with is a trivial
statement like zero or equals zero or
one equals one
because you put it back into itself okay
surprise
so now that i know it's one a now i know
i'm gonna bring it together with two so
um from here i'm gonna sub
1a into two and you guys have been doing
some
tennis equations for ages um you guys
know that you have to actually say what
you're doing you can't just have
random equations just flying around
everywhere
so down here what do we got alpha
squared plus two alpha
okay now i can bring in my substitution
five minus two alpha equals
seven so expand
simplify
bring this guy over okay now
there's a quadratic now you look with me
um how can we how can we what we do with
this
um can it be factorized if i if i make
the
sign out the front a little nicer yeah
can it be factorized
what are we gonna factorize it with
that's totally what i'm going to say
okay now by the way i don't want to
assume
um if you're sorry
i don't want to assume that you're good
at this i remember personally having
heaps of trouble with uh
non-monic quadratic equations and
factorizing them
um you know there's a lot of different
methods um obviously if you don't want
to factorize you can just go straight to
the formula
it'll work but it's kind of excessively
wrong you can do the cross method but i
kind of never really got that if you
like it it's fine
well yeah i don't like it i don't
understand it very well so i don't i
don't teach it
well now see that just do it in my head
doesn't actually tell you anything about
what do i how do i do it so okay i'm
just going to walk you
i'm going to walk you through one way
this is the way that i do it
how do we how do we arrive at this
result well you remember that if i give
you a simpler example let's call it say
this
obviously the important numbers are five
and six right what do i do with the five
of the
times okay so i want
two numbers pair of numbers that will
multiply to that and
add up to this okay and the numbers are
two and three now when you
put a three out the front or any number
at the front it's almost exactly the
same
but instead of having numbers that add
up to five
and multiply to just this number on the
end okay you want numbers that add
up to the number in the middle but
multiply to the product
of these two okay so instead of just
this number on the end
you're actually thinking of 21 okay
which in fact is what you're already
doing it's just that in this case
the a is trivial okay it doesn't matter
so now
you guys get lucky on this one because
three and seven because they're
prime right the number you get at the
end 21
the only two numbers you can multiply
together to get 21
are three and seven well i suppose you
could have one in 21. but that doesn't
really fit with the number that you've
got here
minus 10. okay integers
integers okay so what am i going to do
with
um 3 and 7 they multiply to 21
but i want them to add up to -10 okay
so that's why positive 3 and positive 7
won't cut it
because they don't add to minus 10. i
want negative 3
and negative 7. okay so here's what i'm
going to do with
the negative 3 the negative 7. i'm going
to put in
3 alpha here and then my first number
and then three alpha and then my second
number
but when you look at this right when i
expand this back out i'm not gonna come
back to where i started
right so to compensate i'm gonna divide
by three
okay so this 9 alpha squared will turn
back into a 3 alpha square
and that's equal to 0. okay now if i've
chosen my numbers right
this 3 ought to go back into one or both
of these factors
okay in this case it's kind of obvious
that you know that three and that
three minus three turn back into that
okay
but that's one way i like it because
it's very similar to what you're already
doing
you just have to modify a little bit and
take into account both numbers
okay all right let's come back to the
question
alpha therefore is equal to
right okay so now what
good so just come back to what the
question told you
right um as alpha is
an integer okay therefore
it's equal to that all right now i can
probably finish this off in fact i will
in a second but do you see that's that's
the critical part
um working out what your equations are
and then how you're going to fit them
together
once you've got one it's like a set of
dominoes okay i'll go ahead and put the
working there but
i can pop this back into equation one
when i've got alpha and beta then i'm
just going to pop into equation three
and i'm home and host okay does that
make sense any questions
all right just for the sake of it and
because because i haven't given you
answers for this sheet i might as well
go ahead and finish this
off just so you can verify that the
answer is correct at the end okay
so if i sub this into
i'm going to get two
so i've got one squared
times three
finished okay